merci
bonjour madame bonjour Monseigneur
Mathieu rouget merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous ce matin
et on va évidemment parler avec vous de
la visite du pape à Marseille le pape
qui arrive à Marseille cet après-midi
vous allez d'ailleurs le rejoindre il va
passer 30 heures à Marseille le pape
dans le cadre des 3e rencontre
méditerranéenne quelle importance revêt
cette visite du pape dans la cité
phocéane
François à Marseille ça fait maintenant
15 ans depuis la dernière visite d'un
pape c'était Benoît XVI en 2008 à Paris
hello c'était un moment magnifique et il
va y avoir beaucoup de joie et puis
Marseille c'est une ville je ne dis pas
simplement par
amitié et déférence pour Madame Boyer
mais c'est une ville un peu particulière
en France c'est non seulement une ville
où sont concentrées beaucoup dans le jeu
culturels et sociaux pour aujourd'hui de
manière un peu hyperbolique par rapport
à l'ensemble de notre pays mais ceci une
ville très importante pour les chrétiens
c'est par Marseille que les premiers
chrétiens sont entrés en France et puis
Marseille c'est la ville de Pagnol c'est
la vie d'un parler joyeux et lumineux et
donc accueillir le papa Marseille c'est
source d'une très grande joie et je
pense qu'il va rejoindre les catholiques
et bien au-delà et qui va être aussi un
encouragement pour pour l'Église dans
notre pays alors vous dites ça fait
effectivement 15 ans qu'un pape n'est
pas venu sur le sol français sauf que le
pape dit qu'il vient à Marseille et pas
en France comment il faut entendre cette
phrase le Pape a un discours toujours
stimulant et qui nous déplace un peu le
Pape a voulu insister sur le fait qu'il
venait d'abord pour les rencontres
méditerranéennes qui sont un temps de
travail important entre évêque du
pourtour méditerranéen même si tous les
élèves de France assisteront au discours
du Pape demain matin et le Pape a
conscience qu'il y a des enjeux
économique
socio-humanitaire mais aussi culturelle
et spirituel commun à l'ensemble des
évêques et des églises du pourtour
méditerranéen et c'est cela l'occasion
de sa visite à Marseille mais le Pape a
accepté volontiers de prolonger son
séjour à Marseille il sait très bien que
en célébrant la messe au stade Vélodrome
en plus celui qui était de football ça
doit le toucher particulièrement il
vient célébrer la messe pour l'ensemble
des Français il aime la France il aime
les Français et nous nous sommes très
très heureux de l'accueillir mais est-ce
que d'avoir dit ça quand même ça risque
pas de froisser avec catholiques
français le pape François il s’était un
argentin à la parole très libre très
stimulante parfois un peu provocante et
c'est comme ça que nous connaissons et
c'est comme ça que nous l'aimons alors
c'est une visite qui est placée sous le
signe du défi migratoire visite placée
sur le site des migrants des plus
pauvres il doit d'ailleurs ce sera l'un
de ses premiers gestes se rendre au pied
du Memorial des marins et des migrants
disparus en mer qui est à côté de
Notre-Dame de la Garde c'est une étape à
cœur oui bien sûr alors d'abord à
Marseille on peut pas être à Marseille
sans aller voir la Bonne Mère cette
basilique contrainte de la Garde qui
domine le vieux port et toute la ville
de Marseille qui était un lieu vraiment
emblématique et c'est très important
qu'il y aille il va y prier il va y
prier la Vierge vous savez le pape
François une très forte relation à la
Vierge Marie il ne quitte jamais Rome
sans aller à Sainte-Marie Majeure confié
son voyage il a fait il y a deux jours à
l'intercession de la Vierge Marie donc
il va à la Bonne Mère et pour les
Marseillais quel que soit leur
confession d'ailleurs et leur degré
d'engagement dans la foi la Bonne Mère
c'est un lieu très important et puis
bien sûr on sait à quel point la
question des migrants tient à cœur au
pape François et nous le comprenons
évidemment parce que on ne peut pas se
satisfaire du fait que aujourd'hui la
Méditerranée soit pour beaucoup d'hommes
et de femmes en grande détresse un
cimetière et ça c'est pas acceptable
par l'actualité puisque cette visite à
Marseille est prévue de longue date mais
elle tombe la semaine ou quelques jours
en tout cas après une arrivée massive de
migrants sur l'île italienne de
Lampedusa quelle va être le message du
pape le message du pape va être comme
toujours un rappel du devoir d'humanité
qui est le nôtre le pape François le
sien siège ne remet pas en cause la
légitimité de la régulation juridique
internationale des flux migratoires mais
et nous rappelle un impératif
humanitaire un impératif d'humanité de
ne pas accepter que des hommes et des
femmes finissent noyer dans la mer parce
que parfois avec la complicité de
passeurs gravement coupable bien sûr ils
ont cherché à fuir des situations de
grande pauvreté ou de guerre terrible
est-ce que vous pensez que les pays
européens que la France et du coup à la
hauteur de cette situation
cette remise en ces interventions du
pape je les prends d'abord avant de
penser au pouvoir public pour moi et
pour les chrétiens pour tout
l'engagement que nous avons déjà sur le
plan associatif caritatif d'accueil
d'aide d'accompagnement de contribution
à l'intégration et donc est-ce que nous
sommes suffisamment engagés les uns et
les autres sur ce terrain là et puis
après cela je pense que il y a un
travail à approfondir toujours pour les
responsables publics pour mieux
conjuguer la volonté légitime de
régulation et la mise en oeuvre des
de l'accueil de base absolument requis
sur le plan humanitaire et puis aussi le
dialogue avec l'ensemble des pays pour
que ça veut dire qu'il va appeler à plus
d'accueil notamment de la part des pays
européens puisqu'il est en Méditerranée
répéter une nouvelle fois ce qu'il a
déjà dit on ne peut pas faire comme il
n'y avait pas des drames qui se jouaient
à quelques encablures de nos côtes donc
les États sont dans le rôle quand ils
cherchent à réguler les flux migratoires
mais il y a un impératif d'humanité à
mieux mettre en œuvre aujourd'hui
c'était l'un de ces premiers
déplacements en 2013 à l'an p12a il
s'est rendu à rampe 12 alors il a
dénoncé à l'époque la mondialisation de
l'indifférence est-ce que ça a changé en
disant cette formule de la
mondialisation de la différence elle est
très forte et elle ne touche pas que la
question migratoire il y a toutes sortes
de sujets sur lequel aujourd'hui un
individualisme de plus en plus fort
chacun est emprisonné par son propre
écran fait que nous sommes indifférents
les uns aux autres et le message
chrétien par excellence c'est le message
de la fraternité dans le Christ Jésus le
Fils de Dieu Sauveur qui fait de nous
des frères et soeurs les uns des autres
nous sommes appelés à sortir de la
mondialisation de l'indifférence pour
mettre en oeuvre une mondialis de la
solidarité et de la fraternité et ça
c'est très important évidemment et qui
passe aussi par un DZ de plus grandes
aide au développement pour les pays
concernés bien sûr cette mondialisation
de la solidarité et de la fraternité que
le pape appelle de ses vœux dont par
exemple un saint français récemment
canonisé Charles de Foucauld est une
sorte de figure emblématique ça passe
d'abord par la transformation des uns et
des autres vous voyez chacun d'entre
nous tous ceux qui nous écoutent ce
matin peuvent contribuer à cette
mondialisation de la fraternité et puis
évidemment ça passe par des efforts
renouvelés de solidarité internationale
qui sont donc insuffisants
je crois que on n'est jamais d'abord
arriver à un point
excellent de solidarité internationale
mais on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui dans
notre monde tellement marqué par des
violences par des pauvres décroissantes
par des crises humanitaires il y a
progresser vraiment sur ce plan-là
est-ce que cette crise migratoire elle
est aussi peut-être le symbole d'une
forme de repli sur soi qui s'accroît
d'individualisme qui s'accroît alors je
sais le symbole mais en tout cas elle
est elle est le signe beaucoup de
beaucoup de choses d'abord des lieux de
pauvreté croissante malheureusement des
crises politiques on voit bien aussi le
nombre de pays qui aujourd'hui sont dans
la situation très très délicate je pense
par exemple évidemment à l'Afrique et
puis c'est vrai on l'a déjà dit ensemble
depuis quelques instants il y a un
individualisme croissant auquel nous ne
pouvons pas nous résoudre et auquel
comme chrétien comme évêque je ne résout
pas et nous avons
à nous entraider les uns les autres à
être plus solidaire les uns des autres
certains y compris chez les catholiques
un reproche au pape de trop en fer sur
cette question migratoire et sur la
question des migrants candides vous mais
le pape est dans son rôle quand il nous
secoue un peu et après les réactions les
interrogations les objections sont
légitimes mais le pape est vraiment dans
son rôle quand il a une parole
prophétique pour que nous ne nous
endormions pas trop vite en faisant
comme si il n'y avait pas de véritables
drames humanitaires aux portes de notre
pays alors aussi une forme d'ingérence
politique sur ce dossier non le pape
notre pas dans le champ politique le
pape il est dans le rappel éthique sur
un ton prophétique et cela ne peut faire
que du bien à tous alors Marseille c'est
aussi une ville qui est minée par le
trafic de drogue et par les règlements
de compte est-ce que le pape va délivrer
un message sur un message sur ce sujet
ce week-end alors moi je ne sais pas
exactement ce que veut dire le pape et
je me réjouis de l'écouter sur place
demain matin
et demain après-midi lors de la messe
en tout cas moi comme évêque de Nanterre
j'ai été au premier loge si j'ose dire
des violences du début de l'été dernier
et très très sensible à tous ceux qui se
joue dans nos quartiers difficiles où il
y a aussi beaucoup de belles choses
d'ailleurs beaucoup de fraternité mais
beaucoup de violences beaucoup de
requêtes de repères pour vivre et donc
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est toute
notre société qui a à être attentif à ce
que les violences du début de l'été ont
mis en lumière de souffrance et
d'attentes je crois que on a un peu trop
vite tourné cette page vers le Miami
juillet et que il ne faut pas attendre
la prochaine montée de violence pour se
réveiller à nouveau mais que tous les
acteurs de la société et y compris
l'église ont essayé de comprendre
vraiment les souffrances de ces
quartiers l'inflammabilité extrême des
quartiers difficiles pour pouvoir mieux
répondre sur le plan éducatif sur le
plan aussi missionnaire aux enjeux des
quartiers populaires difficile d'être à
Marseille et de ne pas en dire un mot
pour le pape on imagine oui bien sûr
même si les quartiers nord ont été moins
touchés que d'autres par les violences
urbaines du début de l'été mais
évidemment Marseille c'est une ville
merveilleuse c'est une ville aussi qui a
beaucoup peut évoluer depuis quelques
années mais c'est une ville marquée
aussi par beaucoup de précarité et le
pape il sera évidemment sensible il y a
aussi un sujet qui est cher au pape
c'est le sujet de l'environnement de
l'écologie est-ce que là aussi il va
délivrer un message sur le sujet alors
bien sûr on annonce une sorte de
deuxième volume de du texte fondateur du
pape François sur le sujet qui est
l'encyclique là où datent aussi un texte
qui a rejoint les gens bien au-delà des
cercles des catholiques convaincus cette
question écologique est majeure il
s'agit aussi de l'aborder de manière
juste en mettant au cœur de
l'environnement la dignité de la
personne humaine c'est ce que nous
appelons l'écologie humaine ou
l'écologie intégrale un thème cher au
pape François et sur ce sujet aussi il
faut que que nous soyons bousculer
stimuler pour ne pas oublier entre deux
crises écologiques l'importance des
enjeux de l'écologie et puis pour ne pas
non plus limiter l'écologie à la lutte
contre telle ou telle forme de biodivers
contre la disparition de tel ou telle
forme biodiversité que nous n'oublions
pas que le cœur de du souci écologique
c'est le respect de la dignité des
personnes humaines et là aussi sur ce
sujet les États sont trop longs trop
longs à agir alors sur les questions
écologiques il y a souvent trop de
lenteurs bien sûr il s'agit pas de jeter
la pierre à qui que ce soit le pape
François a grande conscience de la
complexité de responsabilité politique
nous sommes ici dans une assemblée et où
il y a un travail très sérieux qui se
fait évidemment mais on a toujours
besoin d'être stimulé d'être encouragé
aller plus loin et puis vous évoquez
dans l'écologie la place de la dignité
de la personne humaine
j'imagine aussi et que le pape prend la
parole sur ce sujet spécifiquement et
notamment dans le contexte français du
débat sur la fin de vie qui s’annonce
justement débat sur la fin de vie qui
s'annonce le texte aurait dû être
présenté normalement cette semaine il a
été décalé vous auriez trouvé ça une
opportun qu'il soit présenté la semaine
de la venue du papa Marseille alors ce
texte il a été annoncé à différents
moments l'annoncé pour le premier
conseil du ministre à la fin de l'été
fin au début septembre je sais pas s'il
a été décalé à cause de la vis du pape
j'ai plutôt l'impression que il y a
encore un peu des doutes au sommet de
l'État sur la juste position à adopter
ce qui me semble une bonne chose parce
que personnellement je serais très très
réticent à un texte évidemment qui
avance vers le suicide assisté ou
l'euthanasie le Pape a su a eu des cours
même sur le suicide assisté il ne faut
pas aller sur ce terrain là des nuances
entre les deux réalités mais des nuances
seulement et le pape François sur ce
sujet a eu des déclarations extrêmement
carrées à bien des occasions et y
compris en arrivant au Portugal pour les
journées mon de la jeunesse cet été et
j'espère que d'une manière ou d'une
autre et je pense que d'une manière ou
d'une autre il aura l'occasion
publiquement ou dans son coloc avec le
président Macron de le redire fermement
ça veut dire pour vous la loi actuelle
ne doit pas évoluer sur le sujet de la
fin de vie alors je pense que ce qui est
très important c'est un aspect de ce qui
a été annoncé par le chef de l'État qui
est de progresser sur les soins
palliatifs et il y a beaucoup à faire
pour dans notre pays éviter les
véritables déserts palliatifs nous
sommes sur une big Sénat Sénat
l'Assemblée des territoires il y a des
territoires aujourd'hui où ils sont
plats ne sont pas assez développés alors
aujourd'hui les questions de faire une
loi qui à la fois aurait un plan sur un
palliatif et en même temps ouvrirait une
porte au suicide assisté voire à
l'euthanasie personnellement je trouve
qu'une telle loi serait totalement
contradictoire et que ceux qu'il
faudrait dans un premier temps c'est
prendre en compte cette question des
soins impératifs à améliorer faire une
loi qui met en œuvre un véritable
un plan de renouveau des soins
palliatifs et de développement des soins
palliatifs quitte après à s'interroger
sur les manques du système législatif
actuel mais l'idée de vouloir faire une
loi fourre-tout qui fasse passer le
tanazie en ce camouflant d'ailleurs
quelques mesures en fin de soirée n'est
pas acceptable et vous savez c'est très
impressionnant de voir à quel point le
monde médical dans une grande partie en
tout cas du monde médical est très
mobilisée contre l'euthanasie avec un
sentiment parfois de ne pas être
vraiment écouté par la ministre en
charge du dossier et donc moi j'espère
vraiment que cette visite le dialogue
entreprises dans Macron et le pape
permettra d'avancer sur le sujet et que
le décalage de présentation de la loi va
durer encore un peu et que peut-être il
y aura d'abord une soi une loi sur la
maladie quitte ensuite avoir les manques
sur lesquels il faudrait pouvoir
préciser des choses il y a une polémique
sur la présence d'Emmanuel Macron demain
à la messe du François au stade
Vélodrome est-ce que vous comprenez
cette polémique alors qu'on a beaucoup
parlé de laïcité en cette rentrée alors
vous savez les Français aiment beaucoup
les polémiques et une polémique née et
puis elle meurt pas seulement je suis
très sensible à cette présence du chef
de l'État annoncée pour la messe au
stade Vélodrome vous savez comme avec en
ce moment par exemple je suis en train
d'installer dans leur charge pas mal de
nouveau au curés responsable de
paroisses et chaque fois le maire est
présent parfois avec un certain nombre
de ses conseillers municipaux les maires
sont croyants ou non catholiques ou
d'une autre croyance mais il n'y a
aucune
entrave à la laïcité parce que
simplement chacun est dans son rôle est
respecté pour ce qu'il est ça fait
partie de la mission des responsables
politiques de s'intéresser à aux
différentes réalités du pays et les
réalités spirituelles en font partie
inversement d'ailleurs moi comme évêque
je vais souvent à des manifestations
civiles je pense par exemple tout à
l'heure je vais aller à
au grand célébrations qui ont lieu ce
matin pour la fin de la rénovation de la
dalle de la défense j'ai été invité
comme tous les acteurs de du territoire
des Hauts-de-Seine où je suis évêque et
il y a aucune main mise sur quoi que ce
soit mais simplement les différents
acteurs de la société dans une société
qui a à être paisible et respectueuse de
tous et bien son présent aux événements
importants des uns et des autres vous
étiez d'ailleurs au MEDEF et de fait
vous y avez lu la lettre du pape
François qui pour la première fois a
écrit l'organisation patronale la plus
importante en France c'est une démarche
qui peut paraître quand même surprenant
pourquoi cette démarche alors je crois
que c'est le Medef qui avait proposé au
pape s'il le souhaitait d'adresser sous
une forme vidéo sous un texte qui est
toujours la forme d'un texte écrit un
message et puis il était par ailleurs
prévu qu'il y ait une table ronde
interreligieuse où j'étais présent mais
aussi le grand rabbin de France et
également une responsable musulmane pour
réfléchir avec les acteurs de cette
université du Medef sur notre rapport à
l'avenir et je trouvais très intéressant
que des patrons se disent mais voilà
comment est-ce que les religions nous
aident à nous projeter dans un avenir
marqué par beaucoup d'incertitudes mais
aussi pas beaucoup d'espérance et de
fait au début de la Table Ronde
interreligieuse j'ai lu le message du
pape message très beau très stimulant
avec comme toujours des éléments un peu
dérangeants pour les patrons autour par
exemple du rapport entre la
financarisation le capitalisme et les
instruments de travail mais aussi en
fait un message très encourageant très
fort très beau pour tous les chefs
d'entreprise on leur variété chef de
grandes entreprises mais aussi
responsable de PME ou de TPE et cette
semaine
à la fois l'importance du rôle des
patrons notamment parce qu'il
fournissent du travail et du coup il a
appelé à fournir plus de travail aux
jeunes mais en même temps c'est vrai
qu'il y avait ce message sur le fait
qu'il fallait plus s'intéresser au
bien-être humain et moi en capitalisme
mais moi à la finance oui mais un
message qui était pas du tout disons
négatif un message vraiment très
encourageant et qui de fait a été très
bien accueilli et moi j'ai trouvé que
dans cette première journée de
l'Université du Medef et bien qu'il y
ait le discours du nouveau président qui
est d'ailleurs à cité le discours du
Pape puis l'intervention de la première
ministre puis une table ronde
interreligieuse dans un climat de
respect et d'ouverture très large je
trouve que c'est quelque chose qui est
réjouissant pour notre société et en
tout cas moi à titre personnel comme
évêque d'un territoire extrêmement
divers j'accès j'accueille toujours
toutes les propositions d'aller à la
rencontre des uns et des autres parce
que notre société a besoin de dialogue
de rencontre de respect et c'est cela
qui contribue à la fraternité la semaine
dernière Emmanuel Macron a lancé une
collecte pour sauver les petites églises
les petites églises en péril il espère
récolter 200 millions en 4 ans est-ce
que le patrimoine religieux notre
patrimoine notre patrimoine religieux
aujourd'hui manger alors en tout cas la
question du patrimoine religieux est une
belle et grande question à la fois pour
l'Église mais aussi pour la société
parce que une église dans un village
c'est vraiment un pôle d'identification
je veux que Marseille la Bonne Mère
c'est un de soi Marseille sont en train
de la garde ce serait plus Marseille
l'intéressant aussi de voir la place
dans l'esprit des Français est bien
au-delà de la restauration de Notre-Dame
de Paris et qui va être quelque chose
d'extraordinaire et d'ailleurs si j'ai
bien compris hier le roi Charles
d'Angleterre a uni le patrimoine
religieux en allant visiter le chantier
de Notre-Dame et la représentation
nationale en venant rencontrer député
des sénateurs ici même au Sénat donc
cette question du patrimoine religieux
elle est importante pour les croyants et
bien au-delà il faut trouver des
dispositifs innovants parce que il y a
évidemment un poids financier le
patrimoine religieux c'est pas
simplement un poids c'est d'abord une
chance c'est d'abord une culture une
histoire des pôles identification et
puis aussi une stimulation pour la
fraternité c'est le message dans son
porteur et l'édifice religieux mais il
faut trouver des dispositif innovants
alors il est question dans ce cadre là
d'usage un peu plus partagés
qu'aujourd'hui et ça me semble tout à
fait légitime et intéressant à condition
que cela se fasse dans un dialogue très
précis et que l'usage partagé ne remet
pas en cause la mission de l'affectateur
c'est à dire l'Église catholique ça veut
dire que les collectivités
il faut permettre en tout cas aux
collectivités ce qui se fait déjà de
plus aider à la rénovation
l'aide des collectivités à la rénovation
des églises surtout quand elles
appartiennent aux communes où à l'état
pour les cathédrales de la plupart des
diocèses mais il peut se faire moi j'ai
vécu ça dans différentes églises dont
j'ai été curées que par exemple un
conservatoire utilise l'orgue pour des
classes d'orgue qui dit des concerts de
musique ajustée dans les églises mais
toujours en dialogue avec l'Église
catholique puisque c'est l'Église qui
est affectateur des des la plupart des
lieux de culte de notre pays
du Catholic qui est en déclin dans notre
pays il y a moins de fidèles la pratique
est en baisse je crois qu'en 2023
seulement 88 prêtes catholiques doivent
être ordonnés dans notre pays comment
vous expliquer cette désinfections
ou tout des bouleversé pour l'Église et
pour beaucoup d'autres institutions moi
ce que je vois c'est que dans ce
contexte là il y a aujourd'hui des
signaux très stimulants je pense par
exemple à ce que nous avons vécu cet été
aujourd'hui mondiale de la jeunesse de
Lisbonne malgré la situation qui peut
sembler parfois un peu difficile de
l'église en France les Français 45 000
alors qu'on en espérai 30 000 au départ
était la troisième délégation étrangère
de jeunes participants au GMJ et c'était
un moment magnifique lumineux et
stimulant et puis moi je suis le témoin
dans mon diocèse de de beaucoup
d'initiatives magnifiques sur le terrain
et sur le plan de l'annonce de la foi et
sur le plan du service des plus pauvres
donc on est dans une période de
recomposition où on passe d'un
catholicisme ultra majoritaire
du milieu du XIXe au milieu du XXe
siècle et puis la suite aujourd'hui il y
a une nouvelle place que l'Église doit
trouver dans la société française parce
que l'Église mais l'Église je tiens à le
dire elle est bien vivante elle est bien
motivée pour être signe de l'espérance
qui vient du Christ se remettre en
question l'église pour enrayer ce déclin
est-ce que les affaires d'abus sexuels
n'ont pas accéléré alors en tout cas
l'église sur cette question que vous
évoquez ces remises en cause et fait un
travail très important que d'ailleurs
d'autres réalités de la société suivent
finalement donc ça c'est évidemment un
sujet très important l'église sans arrêt
doit se remettre en cause non pas pour
ce calquer sur le monde contemporain
parce que il y a aussi beaucoup de
choses on a parlé beaucoup
d'individualisme ce matin qui ne sont
pas
disons vraiment le meilleur de
l'humanité dans le monde temporaire
l'Église doit sans cesse se réadapter
mais elle doit surtout constamment être
mieux au service de l'espérance qui
m'est donnée par la foi au Christ mort
et ressuscité merci mon Seigneur nature
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
ce matin et je suivra bien sûr à cette
visite du pape à Marseille pendant ces
deux jours j'espère qu'elle apportera
beaucoup de joie aux catholiques mais
aussi à tous les Français merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous